si nosotros nos encontramos en la ciudad
de jarquín hace unos momentos han vuelto
a sonar las sirenas antiaeras como han
hecho en todos estos días de hecho las
autoridades ucranianas han confirmado su
ataques en toda la región en particular
en la castigada que sufre bombardeos
incesantes allí Ha fallecido una persona
un señor de 65 años en un ataque en el
que también hacían afectadas una
guardería y edificios residenciales más
ataques han ocurrido en portaba en sumi
regiones aquí cercanas y de hecho el
Estado Mayor ucraniano ha confirmado que
el total de los ataques ocurridos en las
últimas 24 horas de 85 sobre todo aquí
en el este y en el sur de Ucrania uno de
los últimos ha sido contra la ciudad de
ni Pro Donde ha sido afectada la red
eléctrica y en estas circunstancias el
presidente ucraniano blothenski se ha
reñido en las últimas horas con el
fiscal general de la Corte Penal
Internacional y ha dado la
disponibilidad de Ucrania a colaborar
para la investigación en los crímenes de
guerras cometidos en este país